I can't imagine anyone force our age to
owning a piece of the spotlight at e3
2018 but here we are a bit excited but
mostly surprised that rages back the
first game was received well enough when
it launched in 2011 but it's not quite
open world and comically abrupt ending
all but guaranteed folks would move on
and never look back
but there's hope that this new attempt
could be something special
bubblegum punk marketing aside it's
Avalanche Studios partnership with its
software that's the most enticing aspect
of Rage 2 thus far the team's open-world
prowess and ID's knack for gunplay could
very well be a match made in heaven and
just the thing an unlikely sequel like
Rage 2 needs to keep people talking
considering that it was a bit surprising
when I visited Avalanche in Stockholm
last month to play Rage 2 and I was only
given access to a small chunk of the
game miniscule actually if you consider
that it was merely a single building
with four or five waves of enemies after
chatting with its Tim Willits and
avalanches Magnus Ned force it sounds
like this could be due to the fact that
Avalanche builds its games in phases
splaying out broad foundations before
working down to the finer details a
common practice but likely the reason
for H 2's world at large simply isn't
ready for Showtime trailers remain our
only source of insight into rage 2's
open world and they at least suggest
that avalanches particular set of skills
are being put to good use we've seen a
diverse range of environments and heard
claims of a wild world where
quote-unquote insanity rules Ned for is
fully owns that the team loves to blow
[ __ ] up and that certainly seems to be
part and parcel of the rage to
experience avalanche has worked in
similar spaces before with Mad Max and
multiple Just Cause games giving the
team plenty of opportunities to hone
their craft it feels natural to be
optimistic about their chances
especially with hidden Bethesda as
partners so while we can't say word one
about the quality and effectiveness of
rage 2's new structure or how Avalanche
it really is its telltale gunplay is
immediately recognizable the question
now however is how the added layers on
top factor in is your character develops
new abilities and acquires new weapons
over time
replaying the original rage prior to the
event reminded me how much I enjoyed its
combat in level design the smartly
orchestrated battles in clever AI made
of her engaging fights where using cover
and flanking was key quite the opposite
Forge to encourages you to dive headlong
into a fire fight like 2016's doom you
stand to benefit from fighting face to
face and a quick dash maneuver has been
introduced to help you get in and out of
fights quickly rather than lavishly
dismembering your enemies to earn ammo
and health running into a fray after
killing a few enemies from afar allows
you to pick up energy reserves that
recharge super-powered attacks such as a
ground pound and a force push you've
also got access to an overdrive meter
that can be activated to run faster and
hit harder transforming an imposing
group of enemies into unfortunate
sitting ducks much the same way that you
power up and lay waste to smaller
enemies and destiny - to be blunt twenty
minutes to trips through the same demo
isn't nearly enough time to form a
confident opinion about rage choose
numerous combat mechanics it's fair
however to say that you'll be encouraged
to be both proactive and creative to get
the most out of the game's expanded
potential the not quite a boomerang wing
stick is back and like its advanced form
and rage you can have it home in on
multiple enemies before you let it fly
or charge it up to spin in place once it
lands on a single target for prolonged
damage output
but those just footage from its e3
showcase featured a creative combo
attack with a grenade in a wing stick to
send a disabled enemy flying upwards
while being whittled away this is the
first example of dynamic physics based
systems in Rage 2 that we've seen and it
would be great to know if that's a core
element of the game at large it wouldn't
surprise me to see new games employee
multiplicative systems in the wake of
breadth of the wilds popularity but if
you're very surprising to see it happen
in rage - of all games though it was
probably for the purposes of the demo
the AI we fought against was practically
brain-dead enemies typically just stood
in place and fired away once alerted
without much regard for their own
personal safety trailers have also
echoed a similar lack of urgency it's
probably a safe bet that grunts will be
commonplace in order to encourage use of
your special abilities on a regular
basis but I really hope to find more
challenging enemies populating rage - as
it develops even the boss fight
avalanche showed off look too simple a
giant football helmet wearing mutant
that throws cars is naturally
threatening but its attack pattern was
transparent and seemed easy to overcome
with minimal effort so despite having
played rage too
I'm still not sure what to think about
it it's obviously early days and I've
seen relatively nothing compared to
what's been promised I'm very curious to
uncover what avalanche has in store and
what it can do in tandem with it to make
the best of their combined talents